We have already discussed how the pixel velocity
— or the image plane velocity — is related
to the camera velocity by the image jacobian
matrix. But, these quantities are all interrelated.
If we know some, we can use that information
to estimate others. The jacobian matrix depends
very clearly on a constant parameter: f-hat
— related to the focal length; it depends
on image plane coordinate of a point u and
v; and it also depends on the depth of the
point — the Z coordinate of the point in
3D space. It is interesting to note that the
depth of the point — Capital Z occurs only in the first three columns of the image jacobian matrix.
Let's say we want to use this interrelationship
to estimate the distance to a point.
If we look at a point across a sequence of
images we can compute its velocity in the
image plane. We know the coordinate of the
point on the image plane, and we can measure
the camera velocity using something like an
inertial measurement unit, which would tell
us the rotational velocities and also give
us the velocity. So if we know these three
things then it is reasonably straightforward
to solve for the distance to the point.
Consider now the problem where we want to
estimate the speed of the camera.
So we can again measure the pixel velocity
by looking at some points in a scene across
a sequence of images. We know the u and v
coordinate of a point in the image. In this
case we need to determine the distance to
the point and we can use something like stereo
vision to tell us how far an object is away
from the camera. Once we have these three
pieces of information then we can solve for
the camera velocity. And a technique like
this is referred to as visual odometry. An
odometer is a device on a mobile robot that
counts the rotation of the wheels to determine
how far it is that you have moved. Visual
odometry provides the same information, but
doesn't actually require a wheel and an odometer.
It estimates this by observing how the world
is flowing past the camera.
Let's consider a simple example of visual
odometry.
This is an expression that we have seen before,
but I have highlighted two sub-matrices; they
are both 1x3 sub-matrices. I am going to denote
one of them J sub u and one of them as J sub
v. We assume that the robot is moving in the
X,Y plane and that the world is a constant
distance away from the robot.
We've talked about optical flow. At a particular
pixel coordinate we can determine it’s velocity
in the image plane and that gives us the information
u-dot and v-dot. We can use an inertial measurement
unit. We can use the instantaneous angular
velocity measured by this particular sensor
and we can substitute that into the spacial
velocity vector for the elements omega-X,
omega-Y, and omega-Z. Because the robot is
moving at a constant distance with respect
to the world then Z is known, and Z is constant,
so we can say that the vZ is approximately
equal to zero. There are some elements in
the image jacobian that are not particularly
significant. Their value is close to zero,
so as a first order approximation we can just
leave them out.
The result then is that we can write a simplified
expression for u-dot and v-dot in terms of
vX and vY, the velocity of the camera which
is actually the information that we are trying
to determine, as well as the object distance
— the world distance, the sub-matrices of
the image jacobian, and the angular velocity
of the camera.
We can rearrange this to get expressions for
the velocity of the camera in terms of various
quantities that we are able to measure.
So without having a wheel and without having
an actual encoder or an odometer we can estimate
the velocity of our aircraft, as it's moving
through the air.
Visual odometry is really well suited to robots
that don't have conventional odometers. The
conventional odometer requires that you have
got a wheel and some kind of counter that
tells you how many times the wheel has turned.
If it is a flying robot or if it is an underwater
robot then it doesn't have wheels and then visual odometry is a really useful sensing modality.
So here we can see the underwater robot. It
is using its stereo cameras to maintain a
constant altitude above the seabed. It is
also computing optical flow. And it is combining
that with the height information that comes
from the stereo vision, and combined with
some information from onboard gyroscopes — which
give it its' angular rate — in order to
determine its velocity with respect to the
seabed. If, for example, there is an ocean
current pushing the robot sideways then the
visual odometry will pick this up. There will
be a Y component of velocity and then the
control system onboard the robot can apply
appropriate propeller thrust in order to counter
that. So visual odometry is telling the robot
its true velocity with respect to the seabed.